have a William Goldman quote here and
one of his quotes reads screenplays are
structure and that's all they are so do
you agree with this quote and why do you
think so many screenwriters argue about
structure well first of all I do I mean
it's hard to not agree with William
Goldman who was arguably the Dean of
contemporary American screenwriters I
mean an amazing legacy and I never met
him but I know people who have and just
said that he was just the greatest guy
and so the idea that screenplays are
structure there's a very real way in
which that's true I think ultimately a
screenplay as a pre movie it's you know
it's it's a template and a guide to make
a movie and so there is a structural
component just that like that where it
gets budgeted and you know they do
everything that they have to do in terms
of the pre-production of production from
a writing standpoint it's also true
because beginning middle and end and
subplots and all that stuff to why
people argue about it I think that a lot
of it is people want or are inclined to
think about screenplays at a surface
level like page counts and act breaks
and that sort of thing
stylistic things like you can't have any
unfilmable Zoar flashbacks or voice-over
narration as weak writing because that
puts the conversation in a realm where
it's pretty easy and in reality to write
a great script it's none of that it's
all about immersing yourself in the
lives of your characters and seeing what
emerges from that process and that's not
easy and there is no golden parachute
secret way of doing that characters are
slippery and many of them are hard to
know
and figuring out the relationships and
what they need and what they want and
they're conscious goal and I'm conscious
goal and examining their personal
history which is everything that's
happened to them to find out their
backstory elements which are the key
elements that come forward into the
story that's hard work and that requires
trust and faith that the characters
exist and that's that's a conversation
that people I think are afraid of and so
they'll argue about story structure and
I've seen this flame wars I wrote a blog
a series of blog articles on these
so-called screenwriting rules they want
to talk about these rules there are no
rules if there were rules there would be
rule books there are conventions there
are expectations
there are even paradigms but not rules
and so people want to reduce it to rules
they want to reduce it to formula they
want to reduce it to specific paradigms
to structure as plot when structure is
not just plot there's the external world
of action and dialogue which I call the
plot line that's the realm of the
physical journey that's only half the
story there's the internal world so
where there's dialogue there's subtext
and where there's action there's
intention one of the characters
intentions behind their actions and
where there's the plot line there's a
theme line so the plot line answers a
question what is the story about the
theme line answers a question what does
the story mean and that's the
psychological journey compared to the
physical journey and so that
conversation that we are constantly
floating around that's up there in that
top round the plot line structure as
plot you need to get down in that other
part that's where the conversation needs
to be having that we need to be having
that conversation moreover as I said up
front I think that's where you start the
conversation that's your dialogue with
the story is with the characters that'll
cure what paradigm they use if they've
started with the characters
and immerse themselves in the lives of
those characters more often than not
they're gonna come up with the story
structure out of that and those
characters are gonna be alive and
vibrant so the the again the answer I
think is that people are not comfortable
with that sort of engagement with
characters on an existential level where
you believe they exist and now I'm
asking you to do to get inside their
heads or talk to them or engage them in
conversation that's I think for many
people something that they feel
uncomfortable with if they can say oh
yeah they need to have the the break-in
to act to on page 25 it can't beat me to
page 23 they can't be page 29 is going
to be 25 they're more comfortable with
that because it's it makes it more it
makes it simpler you know so are there
no great writers just great rewriters
I'm not sure that's a quote of yours I
think I found no it's it's there you
know writing is rewriting yeah they've
that's probably more true of
screenwriting than maybe any other
narrative form just because there are so
many layers to get a movie made there's
you as the writer and so you get
feedback from your writer friends you
know the writers group if you're
represented you get feedback from your
managers and sometimes your agents
depending upon you know what your
relationship is with your agents then if
you're working with a producer you get
feedback from the producer and if you've
got it set up at a studio or a
production company or financier you get
feedback from them then if the thing
gets greenlit now you got actors and
directors attached well now you're gonna
have feedback from the director you're
gonna have feedback from each of the
individual actors sometimes they have
their own writers and then you have to
then synthesize what the what the other
writers have done to their characters
and so for example I know Eric Heiser er
quite well and he wrote a rifle which is
absolutely one of the you know all-time
fantastic scripts and I asked him I said
how many drafts did you do and he said
100 now most of those are like changing
a line you know but he would just he
would codify each one just so he knew
you know or dropping a scene or adding
two scenes or whatever so I think
probably out of that
be 10 or 15 giraffes you know but yeah
you you know I tell my students
University students when they've gone
through all this work of developing a
story and then they sit down to write
you know a draft of and I say okay you
just have to understand it's not gonna
be perfect you're gonna have to rewrite
it and they really you know they're not
used to that talk to them two three
years later they completely understand
you know but yeah
rewriting writing is rewriting him
you